hello everyone and welcome back to our
Channel today we have an exciting and
in-depth topic to delve into AWS step
functions if you have been wondering how
to simplify and organize your serverless
workflows on AWS we have come to the
right place AWS step is a powerful tool
that lets you design and manages
serverless workloads with ease whether
you are just starting with AWS or a
seasoned expert we will cover everything
you need to know about AWS step
functions so buckle up and hit that like
button if you are excited as we are and
if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe and turn on the notification
Bell so you won't miss any of your
future contents without further Ado
let's dive head first and before that if
you are one of the aspiring Cloud
enthusiasts looking for online training
and graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers in cloud
computing by learning from the experts
then dragging a show to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cloud computing
in collaboration with Caltech Center for
technology and management education the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete order of the program being
offered so let's Dive Right In the
details and explore the magic behind AWS
step functions so the first thing we
will explore is understanding the AWS
step function challenges so before you
get into the specifics of AWS step
functions let's understand the problem
IT addresses as you build larger
applications with many different parts
managing and coordinating them can
become quite tricky absolutely imagine
you have a bunch of different tasks that
need to happen in a specific order to
complete a big project for example if
you want to build a house you need to
follow a specific sequence of steps like
laying the foundation building the walls
putting on the roof and so on but what
if something goes wrong in the middle of
the process like the wall building part
doesn't work correctly or you run out of
bricks that's where the challenge lies
with traditional methods handling these
errors and coordinating everything can
become a nightmare and here comes the
AWS step functions now we'll have an
introduction to AWS stamp functions so
here AWS time function comes to rescue
with these challenges so AWS staff
functions are like having a master
conductor who organizes and orchestrates
all the tasks in your application it
helps you build workflows as a series of
steps or tasks making it easier to
manage the entire process that's right
just like a conductor guides the
musicians in an orchestra to play their
instruments at the right time AWS step
functions guides you different services
and functions to work together
harmoniously it does this by using
something called State machines so State
machine is like a big map that shows all
the different steps your application
needs to take to finish its work each
step in the state machine is a specific
task that your application needs to do
it could be running a piece of code
processing some data or even making
decisions based on certain conditions
and now we'll see the components of AWS
step functions now that we have basic
understanding let's talk about the key
components of AWS step on Solutions the
first and most important component is
the state each state represents a single
task or a step in your workflow and
there are different types of States like
task choice and parallel a task state
does a specific job like running a
Lambda function or an activity a choice
State makes decisions based on
conditions and a parallel State lets you
do multiple tasks at once that's right
and what's really cool is that AWS step
functions automatically manages the flow
between these states it makes sure that
each task happens in the right order
just like following the steps to build a
house and here's the best part if
something goes wrong during one of the
tasks AWS step functions can handle it
it can retry the task a few times or
even go to different part of the
workflow to deal with the program and
now you can see the state machine
diagram on the screen so this state
machine starts with the start state
which represents the beginning of the
workflow from the start state it goes to
the check items stock that is a state
which is a task state that checks if the
requested item is available in the
stores inventory after completing the
check item stock task the state machine
proceeds to process payment State
another task test that processes the
customer's payment based on the chosen
payment method the notify method state
is a choice state that evaluates whether
the customer prefers to be notified via
email or SMS if the customer prefers
email the state machine goes to notify
customer email state which is a task
state that sends an order confirmation
email to the customer if the customer
prefers SMS the state machine goes to
notify customer SMS state which another
task State make which is another task
paid that sends an order confirmation
SMS to the customer the parallel state
is responsible for running both notify
customer email and notify customer SMS
tasks simultaneously once the task is in
the parallel state are completed the
state machine reaches the end state
which marks the end of the workflow the
visual representation of the state
machine provides a clear overview of how
AWS step functions coordinate in a
different tasks and branches in the
workflow it helps in understanding the
flow and logic of the serverless
application and enables developers to
manage and modify the workflow
efficiently and now we'll see how AWS
step functions work and now let's see
how they will work imagine you are a
chef and you want to bake a cake you
have different steps like mixing the
ingredients putting the batter in the
oven and decorating the cake with AWS
step functions you can define a state
machine for baking a cake the state
machine will list all these steps and
the order they need to happen in so when
you start the state machine it will take
you through each step one by one just
like following a recipe and if if you
accidentally put too much sugar in the
batter AWS step functions can handle
that it can go back and give you another
chance to mix the right amount of sugar
or if the oven suddenly stops working
AWS step functions can pose the baking
process and wait for the oven to be
fixed before continuing and now we'll
see the benefits of AWS step functions
AWS step functions offer several
benefits let's highlight a few of them
first they make your application more
reliable with built-in error handling
and automatic retwites you can be
confident that your workflows will work
smoothly even if something goes wrong
absolutely and AWS step functions also
make your life as a developer easier the
visual workflow designer in the AWS
Management console allows you to see and
modify your workflows graphically plus
it's highly scalable Azure application
grows AWS step functions can handle more
and more complex workflows without a
hitch and let's now forget about cost
Effectiveness you only pay for the state
Transitions and the time your workflows
are running which means you can save
money while building powerful
applications
so these were the benefits of AWS step
functions now we will see the real world
use cases AWS staff functions are
incredibly versatile and can be used in
many real world scenarios for example if
you have a big online store you can use
AWS step functions to handle the entire
order process from receiving the order
to receiving the payment checking the
inventory and finally shipping the
products and let's not forget about data
processing AWS step functions are
perfect for automating data pipelines
where you need to extract transform and
load data from one place to another it's
also a great tool for managing
microservices if you have different
parts of your application running
independently AWS step functions can
help you coordinate their interactions
and now we conclude this topic that is
AWS step functions so to wrap things up
AWS functions are like having a magical
conductor for your applications they
make it easier to manage and coordinate
all the different tasks in your
serverless work close with AWS step
functions you get reliability Simplicity
scalability and cost Effectiveness all
in one package so if you are working on
AWS and want to simplify your serverless
architecture give AWS step functions a
prime and now let's take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers
I will be permanently moving to Europe
with my family so simply learn this
course has helped me back a great job
offered there will be the 60 salary high
we cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are also excited hey I am
Salah
and I am currently living in Nigeria I
am working as Chief Information
Technology officer at aristiles after
working for 23 years in IIT sector in
Algeria I felt that my career had become
stagnant here I wanted to experience
what is like to live in Europe so I
started applying to various jobs there
as someone who is responsible for making
the decision I wanted to upgrade my
skills I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a personal
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing association with
Caltech Chrome Sample video
it's not easy to get access to Caltech
but simply didn't provided that with
this course I had the choice to study
while I continued it with my job
either Technologies like ews and Azure
during the course luckily my new
employers were looking for someone who
knew these Technologies I have just
completed the course but my new
employers were aware that guy was taking
this course and that is how I got this
new job offer with 60 percent salary
high in Finland I will be leading the
cloud computing unit of my new company
I am really excited not just for myself
but for my family as well I have 30
dollars I think I will be able to help
them with their higher studies in Europe
as a father you always want to make
decision that have a positive impact on
your children as for me I am going to
live my dream now I think dreams come
true when you work hard to achieve them
if you found this video helpful please
give it a thumbs up and share it with
your friends and if you have any
questions or if there's something
specific you would like to cover in a
future video leave a comment below
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign